Okay, so we just looked at our first
survey, the ISM Manufacturing Report on
Business. So this is a great intro into
our survey section of the PTM video series
because it highlights very clearly why, as
traders, we use economic survey data.
And you can see that there's two main
reasons we do this. Firstly, for
predicting the stock market direction, and
therefore GDP growth direction. So we are
focusing on our portfolio bias. Okay. And
secondly, clues to look for, for trade
ideas across various manufacturing
sectors.
So we will later in the video series, be
covering macro driven trade ideas. We'll
do this later in the video series in more
detail. But for now, and in this part of
the video series, what we're going to be
focusing on is getting our direction right
in the portfolio, getting our portfolio
bias right.
So throughout the survey section of the
PTM video series, and when we're looking
at this part of the pro trader systematic
process, you will see that all surveys do
provide both functions.
We're looking at this part of the past. So
portfolio direction for stock market
direction, and GDP growth direction, and
potential trade ideas. But we are going to
focus in the next part of the video
series, solely on portfolio direction.
We're looking at this part of the future.
So we're looking at this part of the
project.
We're looking at this part of the project,
but we're looking at this part of the
project.
We're looking at this part of the project,
and we're looking at this part of the
project.
We're looking at this part of the project.
We're looking at this part of the project,
and we're looking at this part of the
project.
We're looking at this part of the project,
and we're looking at this part of the
project.
We're looking at this part of the project,
and we're looking at this part of the
project.
We're looking at this part of the project,
and we're looking at this part of the
project.
We're looking at this part of the project,
and we're looking at this part of the
project, and we're looking at this part of
the project.
We're looking at this part of the project,
and we're looking at this part of the
project, and we're looking at this part of
the project.
We're looking at this part of the project,
and we're looking at this part of the
project.
We're looking at this part of the project,
and we're looking at this part of the
project.
We're looking at this part of the project,
and we're looking at this part of the
project.
We're looking at this part of the project,
and we're looking at this part of the
project, and we're looking at this part of
the project.
We're looking at this part of the project,
and we're looking at this part of the
project.
We're looking at this part of the project,
and we're looking at this part of the
project.
We're looking at this part of the project.
We're going to look at some real-world
examples.
We're going to continue to look at stock
and sector examples as well as we go
through each leading indicator so we can
put everything into context.
Okay, so we're going to move on to our
next leading indicator, the ISM
Non-Manufacturing Survey.
So we're going to be looking at the
service sector.
We treat it in a very similar way to the
ISM Manufacturing Survey for predicting
stock market direction and GDP growth, and
hence our portfolio bias.
So each month, guys, be on top of the ISM
Manufacturing Data and the ISM
Non-Manufacturing Data when the surveys
come out each month.
It's very important.
Use them in conjunction with all your
other leading indicators, and get smart
about your time and work fast on what
matters each month.
Don't get bogged down in too much process.
Focus on what matters.
So let's get into the video and go over to
the computer screen, and I'll see you back
at the desk in the next video.
Okay, so welcome to video number eight.
We're now going to continue with our
analysis into macroeconomic surveys.
And we're going to be looking at the ISM
Non-Manufacturing Report on Business, or
sometimes referred to as the ISM Services
Purchasing Managers Index, or PMI.
Let's just run through a quick recap of
what we've learned to this point in terms
of leading indicators.
We have real interest rates, the yield
curve, investment rate, and high yield or
junk spreads over the 10-year.
We have our M2 money supply accessory.
We have stock market volatility, which was
covered in the IPLT video series.
And we continue our work with surveys.
We've covered the ISM Manufacturing Report
on Business.
Now we're going to be covering the
Non-Manufacturing Report on Business.
So we're going to be adding the Services
PMI into our leading indicator list in the
category of surveys.
So let's have a look at the
Non-Manufacturing Index of Services PMI.
And a preliminary report, so preliminary
report, is published in the first week of
each month.
And there's a final report that's
published at the end of the month.
The link is on the screen there.
You can go to ismworld.org and search for
the ISM Non-Manufacturing Report on
Business.
And the NMI is important.
Why?
Because the service sector represents 80%
of the U.S. economy.
But there is a slight data drawback with
it.
The composite data, so the aggregate data
for the headline index, only goes back to
January 2008.
So when we're analyzing the aggregate
composite index and we're assessing
business cycles,
there's obviously a lot less business
cycles that we can look at versus the ISM
Manufacturing Report.
So purely from a historical data
perspective, the NMI naturally is less
statistically significant than the ISM
Manufacturing Index.
Now, some would argue that makes the ISM
Manufacturing Index more important.
From a traders and PM's perspective, it's
best to basically put an equal weighting
on these.
Because the NMI covers the service sector,
and that's 80% of the U.S. economy, it's
very, very important.
It obviously is very important, even
though at the aggregate level, we only
have data going back to 2008.
You'll see later in the video that
actually the components data of the NMI
actually goes back to 1997.
So from a traders and PM's perspective, we
basically, in level of importance, don't
discriminate against the NMI just because
it has composite data only going back to
Jan 2008.
We treat it as equal importance, if not
more importance than the ISM Manufacturing
Index.
Some in the market would argue the other
way around.
But to be prudent from a traders and
portfolio managers perspective, we just
put an equal weighting on both indices in
terms of level of importance.
The other thing that we have to consider
is that it is in the service industry.
So this includes contracts.
It's non-physical or not real goods bought
and sold, unlike the Manufacturing Index.
Also, in terms of composition, there's
small differences in the makeup of the NMI
versus the ISM Manufacturing Report.
But again, as traders and portfolio
managers, because the service sector
represents such a big part of the US
economy now, we have to treat them in
exactly the same way when using them as a
proxy for portfolio direction.
So when we're trying to ascertain whether
we should have a long, short or neutral
bias in our portfolios.
Now, the NMI has four areas that are
covered to make up the Composite Index.
So there are four components with an equal
weighting of 25% that make up the
aggregate ISM non-manufacturing Index.
So we have business activity, new orders,
employment and deliveries, all with an
equal 25% weighting that make up the
overall PMI for the non-manufacturing
Index.
By far the most important are business
activity and new orders, which we're going
to come on to a little bit later.
But the survey itself surveys 370
purchasing and supply executives in 18
service industry sectors.
Now, in terms of design of the survey,
very similar to the ISM Manufacturing
Index, we are calculating a Diffusion
Index.
So the Institute for Supply Management
calculates the Service Sector PMI as a
Diffusion Index in the same way as the
Manufacturing Index.
So they do this for the four subsurveys or
indicators that have the equal weighting
and then calculate the composite number.
So the respondents are basically
indicating in the same way that the
Manufacturing Index respondents do whether
particular activities.
So for example, business activity or even
new orders for their organizations have
either increased, decreased or remained
unchanged from the previous month.
Now, if you need a recap on how a
Diffusion Index is calculated, you can
obviously go back to the previous video
where, on the slides that you see on the
screen,
you get a full breakdown of how a
Diffusion Index is calculated.
And the Non-Manufacturing Report on
Business, the Services PMI is exactly the
same as the Manufacturing PMI,
in that it's a Diffusion Index of the
subcategories and then the composite
number is calculated.
Now, in terms of how we read it, it's
again pretty much the same as the
Manufacturing Index, just different
subcomponents.
So in terms of our expansion and
contraction, the 50 level is our important
level in the Diffusion Index and the
Composite Index as well.
So we read the Non-Manufacturing Composite
PMI in exactly the same way in which we
read the ISM Manufacturing PMI.
Now, a reading in the composite number
above 50 indicates general growth, so
expansion, in the services sector versus
the previous month.
A reading in the composite number below 50
indicates contraction, so general
contraction in the services sector versus
the previous month.
And a reading of 50 itself indicates that
there's no change in conditions from the
previous month.
Now, in terms of its usefulness, as a
leading indicator, it's great for traders
and PMs to know what's going on in the US
service sector in terms of expected future
expansion and contraction.
And we can glean a lot of information from
it.
So it has a lot of implications for
traders similar to the ISM Manufacturing.
So using it to predict US GDP growth and
global GDP growth.
So a general expectation of overall
expansion and contraction in both the US
and global economy.
We can use it to predict overall stock
market direction and potential returns.
So we want to know which way the wind is
blowing.
Therefore, predicting US stock market
direction and potential percentage returns
of the stock market.
It helps us, of course, understand and
potentially predict likely Federal Reserve
policy.
Why?
Because the Fed is looking at this number
as well.
We also get an appreciation and
understanding due to our general awareness
of overall expansion or contraction and
which way the wind is blowing.
We also get a bias, a potential bias in
our portfolios, whether we should be
running a net long, a net short or neutral
portfolio.
Additionally, we get quantitative and
qualitative information of the industries
that make up the services sector.
So we can use that information to look at
potential individual single stock trade
ideas for our portfolios.
Now, we never rely on simply one indicator
or even a few indicators to get our
potential long, short or neutral bias in
our portfolios when we're predicting
macroeconomic conditions in the future.
So US GDP and stock market direction.
And we also don't use one or just a few
leading indicators to try and get single
stock trade ideas for our portfolios.
We use them all in conjunction with each
other.
So the non-manufacturing report on
business can be used obviously and should
be used in conjunction with our money
market leading indicators that we covered
in videos four to six and the ISM
manufacturing report on business and other
macroeconomic indicators that we're going
to be covering in the rest of the PTM
video series.
We use them all in conjunction together to
get a very good understanding of the US
economy, money flows and of course,
potential Fed policy.
Now, in terms of survey design included in
the diffusion index, we mentioned this
four areas, business activity, new orders,
employment and deliveries.
We are going to be focusing on by far the
most important areas in this video
business activity and new orders.
Obviously employment and deliveries are
included, but they're not as important in
terms of leading indicators because they
are lagging within the index itself.
So the contribution that these four
components make to the overall composite
index, although they are equal at 25%
each, by far the most important
contribution from a traders and portfolio
managers perspective is business activity
and new orders.
What's not included in the diffusion index
just from an educational perspective, and
if you have the time each month to go
through them, they are worth going through
to understand the nuts and bolts of the
survey itself and understand some of the
responses that are recurring there.
There can be some useful information to be
gleaned from that, but nowhere near as
important as business activity and new
orders that are actually included in the
diffusion index and make a very important
contribution from a leading indicator and
traders and portfolio managers
perspective.
So in your own time, you can self-educate
on inventories, prices, order backlog, new
export orders, imports and inventory
sentiment.
We're not going to be covering it in this
video itself.
We're going to be focusing on, as I say,
the most important numbers, business
activity and new orders.
So remember, we're looking at the
contributors here to the composite
non-manufacturing purchasing managers
index PMI.
And we're looking at the diffusion index
and the most important ones contributing
to that composite.
So business activity, what does it cover?
Well, it tells us whether business
activity is increasing or decreasing
overall in the US service sector.
And then new orders reflects the level of
new orders from customers of service
sector businesses.
So the US service sector in its entirety.
So taken together, these two are the most
important ones because we're getting a
general month on month comparison of what
is happening in terms of business activity
and new orders within the US service
sector, which remember is 80% of the US
economy.
Employment is a lagging component of this
survey and will very likely follow
business activity and new orders.
And supplier deliveries gives us an idea
of the efficiency of the supply chain and
can give us an indication of the
bullishness or bearishness of
non-manufacturing or services.
Companies on their supply chain and the
bullishness or bearishness of suppliers
themselves on the supply chain.
But we have to remember that this is the
service sector.
This is not physical goods bought and
sold.
So from a trader's portfolio manager's
perspective, because the supply chain is
not physical or real goods bought and
sold.
So like widgets manufactured in a factory
and there's a supply chain behind that.
From a trader's and portfolio manager's
perspective, supplier deliveries is not as
important as supplier deliveries in the
manufacturing sector and in the NMI
itself, nowhere near as important as
business activity and new orders.
And employment is a lagging component,
which is likely to follow new orders and
business activity.
So we don't completely obviously ignore
employment and supplier deliveries.
They are contributing to the composite
number as components in there.
But the composite number, because it's
affected by employment and supplier
deliveries, we need to dig a little deeper
and look at business activity and new
orders.
And in terms of importance, but a much
higher weighting on business activity and
new orders from a trader's and portfolio
manager's perspective.
Now, there are, as I mentioned earlier,
areas in the survey that respondents
provide information on that are not
included in the diffusion index.
So inventories, prices, backlog of orders,
new export orders, imports, and inventory
sentiment in your own time.
So in time, you can self-educate on these
areas.
That's totally fine.
You've got all the time in the world to go
and do that on your own.
Backlog of orders, in terms of level of
importance, is probably the area that you
should be focusing on.
Why? Because backlog of orders gives us a
general understanding of whether the
service sector in the US is growing or
declining.
If the service sector's backlog of orders
is growing, for example, it's probably
because business activity and new orders
are growing and the backlog is growing in
response to that.
So it's almost like a confirmation of our
previous business activity and new orders
analysis from previous months.
Additionally, if backlog of orders is
rising continuously, for example, it's
likely that the service sector will
require more resources to fulfil that
business
and a better supply chain or a more
efficient supply chain.
Therefore, there will be investment in
employment and the supply chain.
So employment and supplier deliveries will
respond to that as well.
So from a traders and portfolio managers
perspective, in the diffusion index,
business activity and new orders, by far
the most important.
And in addition, responses from survey
participants, not included in the
diffusion index, backlog of orders as a
confirmation indicator.
Now we have in the downloads area, you may
or may not have noticed already in the
downloads area beneath the video, you'll
see a few files there.
One titled ISM Non Manufacturing Index and
ISM Non Manufacturing Index S&P 500 GDP.
If you download these files, you'll see
all of the historical data for the ISM Non
Manufacturing Index and also that data
relative to S&P 500 returns and US GDP.
You'll also notice some charts that have
been compiled from the data.
What we're looking at here is the NMI
Composite Index and you can see the data
only goes back till January 2008.
And you can see very clearly two areas of
the charts where the index was
significantly below 50, which was the
global financial crisis of 2008, 2009.
And also the COVID economic shutdown in
2020.
You can also clearly see that for a period
of a decade, the US service sector at the
composite level, the non-manufacturing PMI
was above 50 from 2010 to 2020,
denoting a full decade expansion in the US
service sector.
You'll also notice in your spreadsheet
downloads, the comparison to quarter on
quarter annualized GDP growth.
And we can see that in the data that goes
back to 2008, that we get negative real
GDP growth quarter on quarter annualized
in the 2008-2009 financial crisis and
during the COVID economic lockdown.
And during the expansionary period, for
the vast majority of that period, we get
GDP growth quarter on quarter annualized
going in the same direction positive as
the non-manufacturing index.
Only on a few occasions did we get one
blip or contraction when the ISM
non-manufacturing index was positive for
that entire decade.
These were not recessions.
These were slowdowns in the US economy.
And there wasn't two quarters of negative
GDP growth as the definition of a
recession.
They were just one quarter of contraction
due to a slowdown in the US economy.
And those slowdowns were temporary, not
least because the Fed is looking at the
same information that the market looks at
and Fed policy responded to the slowdown
to avert a recession.
But if you look at the chart, you can see
in the vast majority of times,
non-manufacturing index and GDP growth
move in the same direction.
Even though the data is only going back to
2008, we can definitely denote that they
move in the same direction.
What we also get is our peak and trough
levels.
So, going back to the previous slide, if
we see the total data composite
non-manufacturing PMI, very simply, we see
around the 60 level.
This generally denotes a peak in the
non-manufacturing index.
And between around the level 40 and 45
from previous times when we've had the NMI
below 50 and we've had recessions in the
US.
Between 40 and 45 is usually the trough
level.
And if we just look at levels of GDP
growth, GDP growth tends to correspond in
the same direction and peak in terms of
percentage growth around the same times as
non-manufacturing index in the US peaks.
So, when the service sector peaks, GDP
growth quarter on quarter annualized seems
to peak as well.
And also trough at the same time, but
moving in the same direction negative and
also troughing at the same time.
And there's generally also a correlation
there between when the NMI slows down and
comes off from its peak, so does GDP
growth.
Also in the downloads area, we get the
annual percentage return data for the S&P
500.
And we compare this to the service sector
PMI as well.
And we get a similar situation when we
look at this versus when we look at GDP
against the ISM services sector.
What we see is S&P 500 annual percentage
returns, not just the direction, but the
actual percentage returns themselves, very
closely linked to service sector
performance.
If we look, for example, in the positive
above 50 area for the decade between 2010
and 2020, if we look between the level of
55 and 60, so 60 being the historical peak
level of the NMI.
If we look between 55 and 60, this is
generally associated with a obviously
positive stock market performance.
But in terms of percentage return, it's
generally associated with between 15 and
20%.
And certainly when we get the peak level
at the 60 level for the NMI, that's where
we see the positive performance, the
positive percentage performance of the S&P
500 peak around 20%.
That level generally is associated with
the NMI being around 60 and peaking an
annual stock market performance of the S&P
500 of about 20%.
If we look lower down in the positive area
in the decade 2010 to 2020, if the
composite number is between 50 and 55,
what does this really denote?
It denotes that there's a slowdown in the
US economy if we're coming from peak and
it generally is associated with positive
stock market data in terms of year on year
performance.
But the year on year performance is at a
lower level, somewhere between flat and
10% positive performance.
So, if we look below the 50 level, and we
look at our periods where the NMI was
below 50, and we look at the GDP year on
year performances there,
you can see from the 2008-2009 period when
we had the global financial crisis and the
US recession,
you can see that stock market performance
year on year at that time was around
negative 40%.
In the 2020 scenario, we were looking at
around negative 8%, 9%, 10%, something
like this,
in the annual performance of the stock
market when the NMI went below 50 during
the COVID economic shutdown.
Obviously, both of those periods and in
the decade in between, the Fed was
obviously very active, especially in those
periods.
But we just denote this as traders and PMs
of what we should be expecting if there's
an economic shock, like the global
financial crisis, like the COVID economic
lockdown,
what level of stock market performance
would we expect when the non-manufacturing
index and even the manufacturing index are
below 50% and what that's associated with.
So we're understanding business cycle
history here and understanding what type
of S&P 500 returns,
US stock market returns are associated
with US PMIs in the manufacturing and
non-manufacturing sector during normal and
abnormal conditions.
US PMIs in the manufacturing.
Now, I want to emphasize here that there
is no rulebook which says if the ISM
manufacturing or ISM non-manufacturing,
so services sector, prints at a certain
level in a month, it means we should
expect a certain percentage exactly stock
market return.
That's not how it works.
What's happened in the past may not happen
in the future.
And also, sometimes in the past, we see
that general rules don't work all the
time.
Of course not.
So if we look, for example, here on this
chart at the end of 2013 and 2014 period,
we can see that the NMI was printing a
number of times below 55.
So between 50 and 55, and we still got
stock market performance.
That was around the 20% level.
But if you fast forward a little bit, you
can see that when, for example, the NMI
starts to go down slightly, so has peaked
and goes down.
So if we're looking at 2015, for example,
and 2016, you can see stock market
performance does actually follow the NMI.
So, yes, as a guide, we can get direction.
Of course, that's the most important thing
for traders and PMs.
We can get a good idea of stock market
direction with a very, very high
probability.
So expansion and contraction in the US
services sector, in the US manufacturing
sector, is a very good guide to GDP and
stock market direction.
What we can't do, obviously, is pinpoint
exact percentages.
So the most important thing is direction,
long, short or neutral bias in a
portfolio.
Now, when we think of the data series
itself, you'll have this in the downloads
area in the spreadsheets.
When we think of that data series, we
mentioned this earlier, the NMI composite
data, it's only available since January
2008.
The components data, so the components of
the survey, it goes back to July 1997.
And we can do a number of things with this
data.
We can obviously look at the component
data in isolation.
So we can look at that as a full history
back to July 1997.
And we can also, obviously, compare the
component data to the aggregate data of
the composite PMI.
Obviously, though, when we do that,
because the composite data only goes back
to Jan 2008, we can only make that
comparison of the component data from Jan
2008 to present day.
So, if we have a look at, for example, the
business activity index, we can go all the
way back to the late 90s.
Here, we've taken the data from 1998
onwards and we get a bit more of a
business cycle history from the service
sector.
So you can see, for example, in the early
2000s, if you recall, during the tech
wreck where the financial markets
collapsed in the dot-com bust,
you can see in 2000 that the ISM services
sector business activity index was peaking
and had a few aggressive blips down.
And that's when GDP began to collapse and
the stock market began to collapse as
well.
And you can see it goes below 50 in 2001,
recovers in 2002, and then we start an
expansionary period in 2003.
But what's interesting is that if you
think of the service sector during the
expansionary period of 2003 to 2008, you
can see that it peaked in 2003 to 2005 and
then started a slow decline.
But really, in a trend declined during
that entire period.
And then, as we know, the composite index
went below 50 in the great financial
crisis before the financial crisis
actually happened.
And business activity nosedived as well at
the end 2007 beginning 2008 and took quite
a while to recover after it nosedived
again later in 2008 after spending some
time back above 50.
So it's good to look at the component data
in the NMI because it does go back a
little bit further.
Obviously, when we compare it to the ISM
non-manufacturing composite index, if we
take, for example, business activity, we
can only go back to Jan 2008 to make that
comparison.
And you can see business activity moves in
lockstep with the composite.
Why?
Because it's contributing to the
composite.
And it's probably, along with new orders,
the most important component out of the
four.
Now, what you can also do in your
spreadsheets is look at business activity
versus the NMI next to each other in terms
of the depth.
In terms of the data itself, not just on a
chart.
And you can make comparisons and look at
periods of stock market history to
understand what was really going on.
You can also do this for the ISM
manufacturing.
So you can do this for new orders as well.
One of the components of the ISM
manufacturing composite index and you can
look at that versus the ISM manufacturing
index itself.
And what we can do is look at periods in
time in stock market history and have a
look at what was going on then for both
business activity and ISM new orders.
So what we're looking at here, for
example, if we start on the left hand
side, we're looking at NMI business
activity versus the NMI composite for the
period August 2018 to December 2020.
And if you recall, when we were looking at
manufacturing, when we were looking at ISM
manufacturing data, August 18 was the peak
period.
And you can see when we look at the NMI
business activity, which is in the first
column, you can see it didn't peak at
August 18.
It peaked at September 18.
On the right hand side, you can see the
NMI itself.
So we've got business activity in the
first column and we've got the NMI in the
second column.
And in August 18, we have a reading of
58.8 and September 18, a peak of 60.8.
And then if we look at both business
activity and NMI from August 18 to August
19, which is the period we looked at
previously when we looked at manufacturing
data, you can see a general decline in
both.
But what's interesting is that business
activity in August 19 was 61 and a half.
And the NMI composite was in the mid 50s.
So in August 19, it was 56.
So if we think about this and we think
back to the ISM manufacturing data,
business activity and the composite is
generally trending lower.
And the business activity number had
peaked in September 18.
But when we think about this in terms of
the ISM, we can look at it on the right
hand side and we can see that the ISM new
orders number was 47.2 and the ISM
composite was 48.8.
So what can we deduce from this?
We can deduce that in the slowdown in
2018, it was a manufacturing slowdown.
It was led by the manufacturing sector,
not the service sector.
The service sector was still in pretty
good shape.
And if you recall, that was the period
when the Fed was cutting breaks in the
summer of 2019.
So we have the July cut, the September and
the October cut.
So what was the Fed responding to at that
time?
Well, we know from the money markets, our
leading indicators from the money markets,
from both government bond and corporate
bond markets, there was stress there.
But also, the Fed was responding to a
manufacturing slowdown in the US.
If we fast forward a little bit and we go
a little bit further in history and we go
to the March, April, May, June 2020
period, if we look at business activity
and the composite NMI, we obviously saw a
big move down because of COVID and the
economic lockdown.
But what's interesting is that business
activity went below 50 for the first time
in March, 2020.
And remember, these are reported in the
following month.
So that number will have been reported in
the first week of April.
And the NMI itself wasn't below 50.
So it was a 53.6 reported in April for
March, 2020.
So what's interesting there is that
business activity is leading the NMI
lower.
And if we go a little bit further and we
go and we look at the April, May, June
period, we see a trough in business
activity at 26.
And we see a massive and we see a massive
rebatt for the May number.
So a massive down move and a massive
rebatt.
If we look at the ISM new orders versus
ISM manufacturing on the right, if we look
at the April, May and June period, yes, we
get new orders going below 50 in February
2020.
But when we get the move back up after the
trough, the May 2020 move higher is
nowhere near as big as the magnitude as
the move in business activity for the NMI.
So when we look at ISM manufacturing
composite number, you can see the recovery
post the Fed rate cuts where the composite
index went back above 50 in January and
February 2020, putting in two readings
above 50.
And then the new orders index, you can see
that it only puts one reading in above 50
at 52.
That was in January 2020.
And then it went below, new orders went
below 50 again in February 2020.
And then obviously had a big move down in
March 2020.
But when we compare this, you can see that
going into the COVID collapse and the
COVID economic lockdown, that new orders
was the first to go.
New orders in the ISM was the first to go
in February 2020.
So we got a warning there, we got a very
strong warning of a manufacturing
slowdown.
And as mentioned, the service sector,
there wasn't really a big slowdown
happening, not occurring like in the
manufacturing sector, even when the
period, even during the period when the
Fed was cutting rates, it was still
reported in the mid 50s.
But then it went below 50 for the March
period, business activity went below 50
for the March period.
If you look at the composite NMI, it
didn't even go below 50 until the April
reading.
Okay.
What's interesting coming out of the sell
off or the slowdown, we know that the
bottom in the S&P 500 was in March.
But what's interesting is when we look at
business activity and the big, after the
big move down from 48 to 26 for March and
April readings, what's interesting is the
big move up in May to 41.
And the big move up in June to 66.
Because when we compare this to new orders
and ISM manufacturing composite, so the
ISM new orders and the ISM manufacturing
composite, when we compare business
activity and the big move down and then
the coming out of it, the two big moves
up.
What's apparent is that the service sector
rebounded much quicker than the
manufacturing sector.
So looking at these historical moments,
it's just good to understand what was
going on there.
The NMI business activity, so business
activity in the service sector is
sometimes a leading indicator to the NMI
itself and even to the ISM, but not all
the time.
So you have to use these surveys and the
rest of the leading indicators.
So our money market indicators, so our
money market indicators, you have to use
them all in conjunction and also the
macroeconomic leading indicators that are
coming up in the PTM video series.
You have to use all of these in
conjunction to understand stock market
history.
And when you're sitting there at any one
moment in time, you don't know exactly
what's going to happen.
You need to have all of the information to
make an informed decision.
If we look at our other important
component of the NMI, that's new orders.
So we can compare that visually on a
chart.
We can look at new orders versus the ISM
non-manufacturing index.
And you can see there's a very, very
strong relationship between the two.
If we look at our table again over that
period, we can look at May 2020.
So we're looking at that period again,
August 18 to December 2020.
And we're looking at NMI business activity
on the left and the composite NMI on the
right.
And we're looking on the right-hand side
of the screen here at a screenshot of the
May 2020 non-manufacturing survey release.
And what we're doing is we are comparing
it to ISM manufacturing as well.
So we're comparing it to the readings
there of the composite level and of
components.
So what we've highlighted here is the May
2020 survey for both the composite NMI and
business activity or production as it's
called in the survey.
So we have the NMI composite and business
activity.
May 2020, the big rebound.
So you can see the series in April for
business activity was 26.
And in May 2020, it was 41.
So this is the big rebound number.
And we know from hindsight, looking at
history, that there was a move also from
May to June of 41 to 66.
But we're looking at the May 2020
situation here.
So imagine you are sitting at this moment
in time and you see the May release.
So this is released in the first week of
June.
And you see the May release for
non-manufacturing.
And you see a massive rebound from 26 to
41 in business activity for the NMI.
And at the time, imagine yourself
comparing it to the ISM manufacturing
data, which was released just before it.
So if you look at the manufacturing data,
we look at production for manufacturing.
The move is from 27.5 to 33.2.
So a change of 5.7 points versus services,
a change of 15 points.
So you'd be sitting here at this moment in
time, looking at this survey and realizing
that both the ISM and services have
probably troughed, but services have
rebounded really, really hard.
And you can see as well from the language
being used to denote the speed of the
contraction reported from the NMI
composite and business activity, that the
direction is still contracting, but at a
slower pace.
How would you read into this?
Well, trough conditions.
Trough conditions have occurred, most
likely.
And there's been a very hard rebound in
the service sector.
Even though it's still contracting, it's
contracting slower.
So we're not out of the woods yet.
But you certainly would not have a short
bias in your portfolio.
You would be long to neutral in the
portfolio.
Now, with a bit of hindsight, we can
understand what was going on in the stock
markets at that time.
If you recall, the COVID lows were in
March, and then the market rallied pretty
aggressively.
And we've highlighted two areas here.
We've highlighted the rebound in the
markets off the lows.
So the rebound in the S&P 500 off the lows
up until the end of May, beginning of
June, and then from June to the end of
October.
Why have we done that?
Well, because we want to look at what the
stock markets did after we realized, or
when we got the information from the ISM
manufacturing and ISM non-manufacturing,
that there was likely trough conditions.
So what's interesting here is that even if
during the March, April and May period,
you were not participating or trying to
pick the bottom, you still had plenty of
time to get in to a long portfolio bias
after that period.
And what we mean by not participating
doesn't necessarily mean you don't have
any position at all.
What it means is that your portfolio is
neutral, and you're not taking a
directional bet in your portfolio either
way.
The point here is that you didn't even
have to have a dogmatic view either way
during the March, April, May period.
Then the ISM manufacturing and ISM
non-manufacturing indexes came out with
new orders and business activity
components showing a trough condition in
the first week of June.
And the business activity number was a big
move higher.
So the point here is that you could have
just not been dogmatic during that period
with a directional bias either way.
So the period March, April, May, and then
when you get the leading indicator signal
from the surveys, that's when you know
that there's trough conditions or very
likely to be trough conditions.
You know, you can't be 100% certain, but
you can be pretty certain that trough
conditions have appeared.
And if you think about the range here in
the green box of the S&P 500 from first
week of June to October, you know, you're
looking at about a range of 500 points on
a starting point of 3,000.
So you're looking at about 15, 16% here at
the index level in a period of three
months where it goes from 3,000 to 3,500
from the first week of June till the first
week of September.
That's obviously a pretty wild move in the
short space of time for an index.
So again, the point here is that you
really don't have to be very dogmatic in
your portfolio at economic turning points
or during liquidity events.
So you can sit back, maintain a non-bias
in your portfolio and wait for the leading
indicator macroeconomic signals.
Generally speaking, you will get returns
by waiting for the leading indicator
signals.
So what's good about being a student of
macroeconomics and leading indicators in
order to make decisions in your portfolio,
you don't have to be a hero.
So we don't want to be in a situation all
the time where we're trying to pick the
bottom in the stock market.
We're trying to pick the top in the stock
market.
We just lean towards a slight bias or bias
when we get confirmation in the leading
indicators.
Because the leading indicators lead GDP
and lead stock market direction and
returns.
The clue is in the name.
They are leading.
So when we see peak conditions and trough
conditions, yes, we get a clue as to the
direction we should be leaning towards.
And that's the direction we lean to.
But we don't have to try to pick bottoms
and sell tops.
This is about on balance rotation and
having the right positions at the right
time, which we're going to come on to
later in the video series.
Having the right positions at the right
time and leaning towards a directional
bias when the leading indicators are
telling us to do so.
We don't have to fight it and be a hero.
So if we think about this moment in time,
I think the NMI and business activity as a
component in May 2020 is good to look at.
Let's just sum it up here.
It's a good example.
So March and April were the months of the
liquidity sell off and Fed injections of
liquidity into the financial markets.
So for the bond markets and for S&P 500
during that COVID-19 economic shutdown.
So we're going to look at the end of the
pandemic.
We're going to look at the end of the
And we're going to look at the end of the
pandemic.
We're going to look at the end of the
At that moment in time, so for the April
survey, first week of May, that's the time
of the release.
We don't know at that moment in time that
it's a trough.
We only know that it's a potential trough
if in the following month, there's a
higher reading for the composite and the
component data.
And that report was for May, which is the
one we've been looking at.
And that came out in the first week of
June.
And this obviously, you know, same
methodology applies to peaks as well.
So when we're looking at peaks, when we
have a very high level, around 60 or above
60 in the NMI,
we don't necessarily think to ourselves
immediately, because it's around 60, it
must be a peak.
It could put in a higher reading in the
next month.
What we have to think about is if there's
a move lower when we come from peak, if
that's going to be a continual factor.
So the previous month was actually a
genuine peak.
At troughs and peaks, the next move, the
next month, doesn't confirm that the
previous month is definitely a trough or a
peak.
What it does do is tell us that there's a
very high potential that it could be a
peak, and we adjust our bias accordingly.
In the May 2020 example, back during that
time in the first week of June, we had a
pretty good indication that the Fed
actions and COVID-19 itself had a big
positive impact on NMI business activity.
So if you think about it in the context of
the historical example and what was going
on elsewhere in the economy at the time,
we had the Fed actions that were huge
amounts of unprecedented liquidity, both
in conventional and non-conventional
means.
But in the COVID-19 economic lockdown
itself, that was an example in history
where the service sector rebounded hard,
because a lot of services were demanded
during that time, because people literally
could not go to work.
So a lot of services were doing very well,
other services weren't doing so well, but
there was a big boom in, for example, stay
at home services, and that had a big
impact.
So when we think of the context of what
was occurring at the time, we had a very
good indication that the dynamics that
were playing out.
And then we see the rebound in the
services sector in the first week of June,
we had a very strong indication that the
economy had probably troughed.
And of course, we were just looking at the
NMI, we were also looking at the ISM, and
we would have been at that moment in time,
also looking at the yield curve.
And we would have had context as to where
the yield curve had come from, and where
it was at that time.
So if we look at some history here of the
yield curve, and we look at where the
yield curve was on the 1st of March 2020,
you can see very obvious inversion there.
And where were we on the 7th of June 2020,
so the end of the first week of 2020?
Well, we look at the Fed funds rate, it's
dropped from 158 to 0.07.
And you can see by the first week of June,
there was a normal upwardly sloping yield
curve.
So imagine we were sitting in that moment
in time, this would be part of our
decision making process as well.
We'd be looking at the yield curve as a
leading indicator.
And what's actually interesting is that
the 10s minus 2s, which indicates a very
high percentage probability of recession,
the 10s minus 2s never actually inverted
during that period.
So if we think back to the period that we
looked at in previous videos, when we
looked at August 2019, where there was
slight, very short term inversion, but it
never really inverted for a meaningful
period of time.
And you can see on the chart, like how
small that was, it was basically just
flat.
Okay.
And if we look at that period and compare
it to say, February, March, April 2020,
you can see that the 10s minus 2s never
actually inverted during that period.
So the indication from the bond market in
the 10s minus 2s was that recession wasn't
going to happen.
Now we know from hindsight that recession
did occur, but at the time we wouldn't
have known that.
So in hindsight, we can look at the data
and you can see this in the spreadsheet
downloads that we had two quarters of
negative real GDP growth in Q1 and Q2
2020.
And you can see where the 10s were in 2020
at their 2020 low, so the spread in terms
of its low, the 10s minus 2s spread.
We can see that towards the end of
February 2020, and that was not indicating
recession.
That was because of massive Fed liquidity
injections through conventional and
non-conventional means.
And we can see that the market was
expecting that.
The market was actually expecting, when we
look at the 10s minus 2s spread, that
there would be Fed intervention.
And you can see for the rest of 2020, this
is the spread going higher and
representing a normalization of the yield
curve.
So it's always good, guys, to look at how
the leading indicators were behaving at
certain periods of time in macroeconomic
history.
Because it gives us a better education for
when we use them in the future, and we're
placing ourselves at any random moment in
time.
And we're looking at all of these
indicators.
We can understand and appreciate what
happened in the past, what is happening
now, and what is likely to happen in the
future.
Now, another feature of the
non-manufacturing index, the services PMI,
is that we have, like the manufacturing
index survey, we have a qualitative
assessment inside the non-manufacturing
index.
And again, we are looking here now at the
example from May 2020.
And you can see, when we look at the
industries, we can see, we can look at the
industry performance for growth and
contraction.
So we have our 18 industries, and in May
2020, if we're using this example, four of
the services industries were reporting
growth in May.
And that was agriculture, forestry,
fishing and hunting as an industry,
finance and insurance, public
administration, go figure, government and
public administration services and
companies servicing government were
obviously doing well at that time.
And information.
There were 14 industries that were
reporting a decrease in business activity
or industry performance at that time.
And that was mining, arts, entertainment
and recreation, and other services,
construction, educational services,
professional, scientific and technical
services, utility services.
Utilities, wholesale trade, accommodation
and food services, management of companies
and support services, real estate, go
figure, rental and leasing, transportation
and warehousing, healthcare and social
assistance, and retail trade.
Now, what we've done is here to look at a
few examples of what you might have been
thinking at the time, is that we've
highlighted two areas.
So we've highlighted agriculture,
forestry, fishing and hunting, which was
reporting growth in May during that
period.
So may versus April.
And it was one of the only four industries
reporting growth.
And we're looking at, you know, one of the
sectors that was really hit hard by the
COVID-19 economic lockdown and recession
during that period.
We're looking at accommodation and food
services.
So imagine yourself going through this
report at that moment in time, and at any
moment in time, when you're downloading
the report, looking at the data, but
you're also looking at the qualitative
assessment too.
Imagine yourself in this situation and you
were seeing this stuff.
So let's have a look at a statement in the
qualitative statements that are coming out
from these sectors.
Let's have a look at accommodation and
food services first.
Let's read this out.
Current operations have been reduced to
accommodate a slowed economy, but the
business is taking time to review
operations and implement more efficient
processes.
Purchasing has slowed for client facing
goods and services, but has increased for
internal operating supplies and services.
What are we getting from agriculture,
forestry, fishing and hunting?
Demand seems to have bottomed out.
And we're seeing signs of increasing
interest.
Inventories of finished goods are
extensive.
So production will slowly rebound in the
coming months.
So what is happening here?
Agriculture, forestry, fishing and hunting
are literally communicating to us
qualitatively,
in words that conditions have bottomed and
they're bullish.
Inventories are high and they're expecting
a rebound and for the rebound to continue.
What are accommodation and food services
telling us?
Well, they're telling us that business has
been reduced to accommodate the current
economic environment.
And they're taking time to review the
situation.
Well, they're obviously reporting a
slowdown, a decrease, May versus April,
and they're communicating to us no
visibility.
So two very, very different qualitative
responses here.
Elsewhere in this qualitative list of
statements here coming from the different
industries, you know, you might pick up on
some interesting stuff as well in other
areas.
So for example, in this list of
qualitative statements, online education
for educational services is a very strong
indication of a rebound or strength in
that industry.
Additionally, if you look at near the
bottom, you can see retail trade.
So retail trade, COVID-19 had obviously a
big impact there.
You know, one company here is responding,
saying that they successfully kept 90% of
their retail locations open to the public.
And the 300 plus headquarters has been set
up for staff to work remotely to support
the retail locations.
And there's obviously conflicting
statements as well from public
administration services.
So if you look at the statement there,
they're saying COVID-19 is still impacting
our revenue significantly and the prices
we are paying for goods and services.
Obviously, that conflicts with the
previous slide where they were reporting
growth.
If you look at finance and insurance,
they're saying extremely busy with small
business administration paycheck
protection program.
So these were the paycheck protection
subsidies that were going out paid for by
the US government at the time.
And yes, this is in line with the growth
reported on the previous slide.
So that's finance and insurance companies
servicing that public service.
So you can see that when you read through
all these things, you can get a lot of
clues as to what's going on in the economy
at the time.
So May 2020 is a good example of this.
And we're going to concentrate on
agriculture, forestry, fishing and hunting
and accommodation and food services here.
And remember, just try and put yourself
into the shoes of somebody that was
looking at this at the time.
Or, you know, think of yourself when
you're looking at a new survey, survey
that's come out cold.
And you're looking at it at any one moment
in time in the future.
At this stage, all we have is some
qualitative statements and some data to
show growth and contraction in certain
areas.
So certain industries, you would obviously
do research on these qualitative
statements and do further work to
potentially generate some trade ideas.
So, for example, in May 2020, we got that
strong message from the agriculture,
forestry, fishing and hunting industry.
If we went away and did some work on that
industry, on that sector, we may have come
across a stock called Yeti.
Yeti.
What does Yeti do?
Well, Yeti provides products for the
outdoor and recreation markets.
So we're talking stuff like coolers, seat
cushions, beverage holders, security cable
locks and brackets, stuff like this.
Okay, bottles, t-shirts, caps, gear cases,
you name it.
Yeti does it.
And just look at the performance of this
stock relative to the S&P 500.
If we look at a point of origin in the
first week of June, when the
non-manufacturing index data and these
qualitative statements were released.
We're looking at an index of 100 and we're
looking at the first week of June till the
end of the year 2020.
Okay, we're starting at the point of
origin in the first week of June at 100
and we're comparing Yeti to the S&P 500.
So over that six month period, how did
Yeti, our outdoor and recreation stock,
compare to the S&P 500?
Well, Yeti in absolute terms was up 112%
over that six month period.
And the S&P 500 from first week of June
till the end of the year, during that
period, the S&P 500 was up 23%.
So we're looking at here, guys, roughly a
90% outperformance in a six to seven month
period in 2020 from the first week of
June.
When we compare Yeti as an outdoor
recreation stock compared to the stock
market S&P 500, which obviously is a
pretty phenomenal performance,
outperformance that is.
Now, Yeti itself as a stock is actually
not part of the S&P 500 index.
So, yes, we can compare Yeti to the
broader market of mega cap and large cap
stocks.
But if we compare Yeti to the IWM, the
Russell 2000 ETF during that time, this
would be more accurate because Yeti is in
the IWM.
Yeti is part of the Russell 2000, or it
was back then anyway.
This would be slightly more of an accurate
exercise to compare the performance to the
IWM.
The IWM was up 40% during that same
period.
And we know Yeti was up 112%.
So we're looking at about a 70%
outperformance here.
So as an example, in May 2020, listening
to the very strong statements coming from
the outdoor and recreations industry,
listening to that very strong message,
doing further work and finding the stock
or stocks that were going to rebound,
definitely made returns for you.
This happens time and time again in both
manufacturing and non-manufacturing
reports.
We get fantastic qualitative data,
especially at turning points.
What we can also look at here is a stock
called QSR, which is a restaurant brands
international.
We look at the same period in time.
This company owns franchises like Burger
King, Popeyes, and also the coffee shops,
Tim Hortons, mostly in Canada.
We can compare QSR to the S&P 500 there to
be looking at accommodation and food
services.
Obviously, these guys were reporting a
difficult time in May 2020, not giving any
visibility.
So this industry was giving no visibility
in the qualitative statements in the NMI.
And you can see the stock performance
versus the S&P 500.
The stock was up during that period around
9% and the S&P 500 was up 23%.
So you're looking at basically a 14%
underperformance of QSR versus the S&P 500
during that time.
So again, if you went through the
qualitative statements at that time, you
were hunting around for potential short
ideas.
You will have done further work,
obviously, than just looking at the
qualitative statements and just randomly
picking a stock.
You will have done further work on all the
processes that we're going to give you in
the BTM video series.
And you may have bumped into a nice
situation here, like QSR, where, yes, the
stock didn't go down.
We obviously want, ideally, situations
where stocks go down for our shorts.
But a nice situation like QSR where you
get underperformance relative to the
market and relative to your longs is still
acceptable.
And if you look at, for example, the
performance of QSR, where there were many
times during that period up until the end
of October, beginning of November, where
the stock was actually down.
So you could have actually made money on
the short as well, not just as an
underperformer in the portfolio relative
to your longs.
So in terms of using the NMI for trade
idea generation, we use it in exactly the
same way when we assessed the ISM
Manufacturing Index.
We're taking quantitative data and
qualitative statements to enable light
bulb indications or clues as to where to
look in the stock market to get potential
trade ideas.
So, you have to go through a monthly
quantitative and qualitative process of
organizing the numbers and statements and
look for turning points or trends in the
data, not only at an aggregate level, but
also at the sector level.
And do not obviously just go through ISM
Manufacturing or NMI data and quantitative
statements and then just randomly pick
stocks.
That's just stupid.
Okay.
And you have to go through all of the
other processes that we're going to give
you in the PTM video series to identify
potential stocks that are going to move
from the indicated trends in the ISM and
the NMI.
Unfortunately, there just aren't shortcuts
here, guys.
The only way you can save some time is
perhaps having a third party organize all
the data for you, but you're going to have
to generate the trade ideas.
You're going to have to go through the
data, understand the qualitative
statements, interpret them correctly, get
the light bulb indication and clues of
where to look in the stock market.
And then you're actually going to have to
look at industries or sectors in the stock
market and find the stocks that are going
to be benefiting from current conditions.
There's no shortcuts.
You have to do the work yourself.
You have to generate your own ideas.
Additionally, do not rely on the ISM and
the NMI as the only places you look for
potential trade ideas.
Again, we mentioned this in the previous
video.
There are multiple places to get trade
ideas in the financial markets and in the
world in general.
Now, additional to qualitative statements
coming from each of those 18 industries,
we also get our quantitative data.
And you'll have this in the downloads
area, similar to ISM manufacturing
sectors.
In the NMI, we can look at service sector
or the service sector industries, and we
can rank them and color code them for heat
map.
So again, we've got in this analysis
available in the downloads.
You can update this every month yourself.
Just learn how to use the spreadsheet
properly.
We've got the six months from July to
December 2020.
And we're ranking and sorting in
descending order in terms of growth in
December 2020.
And just as an example here, if we look at
our two sectors that we were just looking
at, we were looking at agriculture,
forestry, fishing and hunting.
If you look at the second half of 2020,
from July to December, you can see that
we've got growth indicated in every month.
So month on month growth in every month.
And you can see the rankings go from three
to five to 12, and then four and seven.
So essentially, the growth is getting on a
relative basis stronger relative to other
industry sectors, then going steady
towards the end of the year.
And then you can see it, for example, in
accommodation and food services, second
from bottom.
We're going from growth, moderate growth
in July, some quick rebound at the
beginning of, in the middle of summer in
August.
And then growth as we get towards the
holiday season, in terms of rankings,
starts to go down slightly.
And then we get contraction in December.
So if you recall, in May, the May 2020
report, which was reported first week of
June, for accommodation and food services,
they reported contraction.
When we look at what happened for the rest
of 2020, we got some growth in the sector.
And then we saw contraction at the end of
the year.
So again, you can look at this at the
aggregate level.
But you can also look at this at the
component level for each sector as well,
as we did with ISM manufacturing.
So download the spreadsheets, figure out
how the spreadsheets work.
And you can update this every month when
the NMI survey comes out and look for
trends and turning points in the data.
What you can also do is obviously take
those qualitative statements and stick
them in the NMI spreadsheet.
Again, that's a very useful exercise to go
through every month.
If you're taking the qualitative
statements and sticking them in the
industry comments sheet, because you're
much more likely to internalize what is
being said.
So in terms of further work on the ISM
non-manufacturing reports on business,
we've looked at the main areas for the
diffusion index, business activity and new
orders.
So in your own time, go away and look at
the areas that are not included in the
diffusion index.
Do a bit of work around those and
concentrate mainly on backlog of orders.
Again, guys, got to have a self-starter
mentality here.
Learn the intricacies of the composite
index components and the data sets that
aren't included in the composite index.
We're not indulging in smooth feeding and
copy trading here at ITPM.
We expect that you want to be good at
this.
Therefore, you're going to be doing your
own work, generating your own trade ideas
and making your own returns.
What we're doing here is starting you off
very strongly in the right direction.
So let's summarize all of this for the ISM
non-manufacturing report on business.
It's one of the most important leading
indicators out there for professional
traders and portfolio managers.
Why? Well, we know US GDP drives global
GDP and stock market returns in the US and
to a large extent, the rest of the world.
We're using it as a leading indicator in
conjunction with the ISM manufacturing
index and the components of that to
predict US GDP, stock market direction and
potential stock market returns in the US
and potentially global GDP.
And stock market returns outside the US in
the rest of the world.
They are both as important, remember, as
each other.
Yes, the manufacturing index is 20% of the
US economy.
The services sector is 80% of the US
economy.
But from a trader and portfolio manager
perspective, we treat them with equal
importance.
Now, we don't only use the NMI in
conjunction with the ISM manufacturing
survey.
We also use it in conjunction at any one
moment in time with the money market
indicators that we've covered so far in
the video series and other leading
indicators that we're going to cover in
future parts of the PTM video series to
predict turning points in the business
cycle and trends in the business cycle.
And therefore, our portfolio direction.
So again, it's useful for getting a bias,
a net long or short bias or even neutral
bias in the portfolio.
Similar to the ISM manufacturing index
with the NMI also, we can look for clues
at a sectoral level as to how companies
will report their earnings in upcoming
quarters.
Therefore, the NMI can also potentially
help us to generate trade ideas in single
stocks for our long short portfolio.
So not just a bias for the portfolio, but
also what we should be looking at to be
long and short in the portfolio to obtain
that bias.
So it's a great leading indicator, the
NMI, it's a great leading indicator that's
going to enable us to be right somewhere
between 60% and 80% in our estimation of
the US economy to get a directional bias
in the portfolio of long short or neutral.
But it's also useful for us at a sectoral
level of single stock trade ideas and we
can use it in conjunction with the money
market leading indicators that we covered
in videos four to six and the other
macroeconomic surveys or indicators that
we're going to be looking at in the rest
of the PTM video series to get a solid
understanding of the US economy.
Money flows and potential Fed policy when
we use it in conjunction with the ISM
manufacturing POI and other tools that
we're going to be covering, we add another
powerful weapon to our macroeconomic
survey armory.
So closing the loop, this is what we're
going to do.
We add the ISM non-manufacturing report on
business, the services PMI to our leading
indicator list of surveys and our bigger
list of leading indicators overall.
So we have our money market indicators,
real interest rates and the yield curve in
the government bond market.
We have investment grade, high yield and
junk spreads over the 10-year, that's in
the corporate bond market.
We have our accessory, the M2 money supply
growth and we have our stock market
volatility from the IPLT video series.
In our surveys list, we are now adding the
ISM non-manufacturing report on business
to the survey list and that is joining the
ISM manufacturing report on business.
So what we've done in the last two videos
is we've covered the main PMIs in the
United States, the manufacturing PMI and
the services PMI.
That's it, we have covered purchasing
manager indices, the main ones in the
United States.
We're going to leave now PMIs and we're
going to now look at other surveys, other
leading indicators in the United States
that are very important.
Next, we're going to be looking at the US
consumer.
So instead of going back to the desk,
let's get straight into it.
Let's start looking at the US consumer.
I'll see you in the next video.